in this capture we will see
the backtrack king algorithm sturges then
we have seen the definition of a problem of
constraint satisfaction
what it requires is that we
define a set of variables that
for each of the variables define
an area of ​​potential value for these
variables
we have to define a set of
constraints to satisfy and in our
search space that we explored for
solve our satisfaction problem
against one we have a place that corresponds in
made to a value assignment
uncertain or at all and sees all
variables and the goal is to find
an assignment that will be complete
that is, who will assign a value
the set of all the variables of the
problem it's going to be compatible this is at
to say that it will violate any of
constraints of our set of
constraints then the first suggestion
algorithms that could be considered
it will be a nice so search
in the graph of assignments the big
strong and the next structure so in
what if graffiti a draw or an eto'o
would be an assignment for the root of
our graph so the initial state that
would correspond an assignment that is
empty we associated no value with any
variables in our function of
transition for our graph what
could make his signed a value to
a variable that has not been yet to
sign and more the bus function that
would determine if we reached our
goal not she would return true if
the assignment is complete and
competitive
so this is an algorithm that is very
general very simple it corresponds in
done to an in-depth research of
purges and since the solution has to be
which must sign a value to
each hatred variable a solution
must necessarily appear
depth n
in our graf note
now there are two problems associated
to this this algorithm where are we going
to correct for an algorithm
improved that will be the bac tracking
search the first one referred to the
size of our search notice our
graph actually corresponds to an arm or
each of the naked actually we generate
several assignments possible and
each of these new assignments
when generating other assignments a little
more complete and a website and
now consider what is the
size of these lookup tables there and
well at the root so at the first level
we have a number of children who are cold
and where m and the number of variables and
the size of the domain since at each
level we can choose any dn
variable and for each of these
take any of the values
so that's news once
assignments possible so once
children the successor to the root
this is the next level but here we have
a - a variable that is among
which one can choose to make a
assignment but we still have values
possible so we sit here for
simplify that all variables have
the same number of possible values ​​in
their domain so in this case we have
half men minus 1 time successors
for each of the generated nudes each of which
and our successors generated by the
stories and if we continue like this
up to level 1 that means
that would be factorial so fred -
0 reindeer -2 7 8 times hate
complete assignment and that's it
in fact so ban lx of at the
hate number of knots in our works
of research
in fact that is it is to be
far too much company number of us
that we need to represent our
space our space of six missions
among others
this way of generating successors
she ignores skin as small as
activities
to agitate assignments in our
status so assigned is aa red then w to
ab it's the same thing
sign w to abeilhan first s to 1 red
afterwards is actually if we held
account of the community activities
could have some to the n2 and to do
what are we going to do
so the first reading to improve
our crisis and to consider that at each
level there is only one variable that is going
be assigned to different values ​​so
when I go maybe to the root I
firstly choose one and one
only variable and this variable I'm going
consider all these possible values
and at the next level
so this gesture is also research
again choose a single
variable and then I'm going to assign to this
variable all these possible values
so I'll wait for my exploration at
all assignments of this value
there but at these different words the
second idea
in fact it is to notice that it serves to
nothing is useless to continue signing
variables if there are already
constraints that are violated in my
partial assignment so if I have a
association that is already generating conflict
it's nothing to make me
complete association to realize to me
that in fact my assignment completes them
yes but the compatible steps is
something that I could have detected
long before the host idea is that in
done when we are going to explore our graph
we're going to back up or in English backtrack to
whenever one finds oneself at a
assignment we can not generate a
new assignment which she would
compatible so we can not add a
new assignment of a variable without
violine contrary
and now if we combine these two
ideas there to know choose only one
variable at each level when we do
assignments and retreats when
arrives at a place we have no more
new assignments compatible one
can generate we finally get our
algorithm that is the tracking crate souk
and it's going to be the algorithm of
basis we will see in this capsule
is and next capsules to develop
effective solutions to problems
of satisfaction against is then we have a
pseudo code here the algorithm is so
start with bac tracking
search where we give as argument a
variable csp that will correspond in fact
all the information that corresponds to
the definition of my problem so that's
what the set of variables
what is the domain of variables
what is it to counter them so it's a
kind of data structures that
contains all this information
parking either I see it actually calling a
method that are going to be and cursive which is going
to be called the same on the inside in
giving the initial condition to know
an assignment cities and by the way
obviously the definition of their
problems csb is so notable rites
backtrack he'll take argument two
things will take two things he'll
take a summons is the
definition of the premium csb is what will
make his first mores detected is
what the assignment is complete
if so I will return this
assignment therefore has it in fact when
will arrive a full assignment
because we will not allow ourselves to
continue if we come to
assignments that are that violate the
constraints that are not compatible if
we arrive at an association assignment
complete one necessarily has a
assignment that is also compatible
and we will return this assignment there
otherwise we will choose a variable that
is not signed by me yet
assignment so we see a method or
a function that will make that choice there and
that's a variable valve missed x
then two are your interests on
all the possible values ​​of another
variable x and have reiterated in a
some order 7 out of the water is going to be
given by another method that we are going
call ordinate value yes
pardon I jumped here so the method
varna sign your make the choice of the
next variable and the method or the
ordered value function will she ordered
the values ​​of the domain of x in a
order that will allow us to execute
more quickly the faster
possible our note search for
space and we're not going in fact in
other capsules that there are different
choice of scheduling values ​​that
will give more or less performance
good so that's something we
will see later so for now
can ask what value to give
variable data the values ​​speak
in a random order
it will be an example of ordered value
so for each value what are we going
to do thereafter
in this loop there is we are going
check
can i have signed x to the value
v and add that in my assignment
current and get one more time
assignment new assignment which is
compatible no that violates any of
constraints csp if that's the case
will add my assignment so
I add and sega lift the assignment
I will also take the field of
x in the csp and I'm going to change it to
that they be in the fact that they contain
a single value and that it is the
value that ge has signed to x so their
larvae and generate a new csp that I
will call if they yearn for you
as a kind of copies of csp but
where the field of ex-charged and 29 years in
account not only the uv value to those
to remember another a third
function that is infer years and the goal
of a ferrand it's going to be to simplify the
problem csp so the problem if they
aspire stars what will do is
that reference will try to reduce the
domain of all variables will be
not been assigned yet so this is a
thing that dolphin inferences that a
something other than reference to your temptation to
do if to detect in advance if
the assignment will necessarily lead to
conflicts
so is it possible to
see from the assigned party to
the actual whatever whatever the
assignments will do in the future
eventually we necessarily see
to arrive at conflicts that will not happen
not to satisfy the constrains so
inferences must do it's two things
there we return to csp stars
simplified and if a conflict has been detected
will return a variable
boolean who's going to be so I called
ok here who wants to be in the pit 6 e
no conflict conflict sorry then sea
hawk is equal to true but in this case
we will call recurring
backtrack with our assignment
increased with togo is not what we have
added eghezée calvet and the new
definition of csp with domains
reduced is that it's returning us a
result if the result is not fake that
means that later then more
deep in the execution did not detect
of confit when we will return the
result that was found so at this
moment too
it means that the result has made
possibly in the recursive call on
has reached this this part for no
find a very complete assignment
when it's done here it's like that
return this assignment complete the
higher up in the execution and
so that's the body or result is
not wrong and so results it takes by
against what we will do is we go
remove our assignment we were in
train to consider and xigua life on
will remove assignments and that's okay
bring us to a next next
iteration we will take a new
value of the variable signed the
variable x we ​​go the office is an error
can not correspond to an assignment
which compatible and we will start again here
we go through a tiny loop
all this loop here without ever
succeed in returning to the result that is
not wrong but in this case we're going
return must and if it will match
to a noble tale failed to find
no new assignment that does not
would not eventually lead to a conflict
so no assignation that led
possibly an assignment that was
complete and which were compatible
here is an illustration of the execution of
the backtrack king sturge algorithm for
some few operations have
started early with an assignment
empty where we did not sign any color to
none of the states of australia and
then from there, we choose
a variable in this case the variable
which has been chosen is that
corresponding this state if then
consider having an iteration on all
the possible colors that we could
assign this variable which we take the
1st then we generate the successions so
we will explore other assignments
more complete or there in this case we have
chosen is it is also that we will
consider signing it 1 every
values ​​that are compatible
so that means we're going to have a
backtrack appetizer for this
assignment there and this assignment there
because an assignment that would have to
sign this state there to red
in fact we would not have passed the test of
compatibility and so would not have
called once backtrack so
recurrent
so that's an example of the execution
first iterations of the sentry box
kingson